Kendra sells Hollywood season two
before we get to you know giving you
your flowers and congratulating you on
all the amazing work you're doing in
real estate I want to talk about how
episodes one and two kick off
you are frustrated you're upset you're
in tears you really feel like you're
stuck
why I mean look
it's really hard being a single mom you
know and alone
starting a new career
how scary is that really really scary I
love being a single mom I love real
estate but sometimes when you know it
just gets to be a lot a lot of pressure
because
um
you know I'm not a perfect person
I have a past
I have two kids to take care of on my
own Financial person in my life I don't
have a nanny I don't have housekeeping
so you know it's a lot for one person to
juggle all at once but
I know I'm strong enough to do it
and I'm honestly I'm on this road I have
dreams I have ambition I have
so much to to reach and I'm not going to
stop yeah I mean you are the epitome of
Tenacious we see you really upset in the
beginning of this show what do you think
ultimately it was that helped you break
this cycle of feeling stuck because you
do ultimately sell your first home I do
well I look I I have to admit that I do
struggle with some mental health
issues and some depression so
you know I spent
for almost five years off camera you
know getting myself
healing and going through therapy I did
a lot of work on myself to get myself in
a strong strong place
so here I am doing real estate on a TV
show and I'm enjoying it but
I'm not safe from you know the Past
coming back to
distract me from my my life now
and it gets really hard because I've
done so much work on myself for my own
life and for my children that
it gets really hard that
you have done so much work and it's not
fair sometimes that I that I have to pay
that price because other people have to
talk about me I 100 respect everyone and
um
I wish everybody well it's just that
I've done my own work to to go to move
forward in my life
I don't have a lot of time to keep
thinking about what I did when I was 18.
I'm here now at 37 years old I'm a
single mother I created a whole life
after Playboy do you feel like that
label is just very difficult for you to
try to escape yeah when I signed up when
I chose to go to the Mansion at 18 years
old
there wasn't cameras around or a show I
signed up just to party and have fun it
was it was life it was part of your life
yes so when the cameras came in and it
all of a sudden Our Lives just changed
overnight you know and it's such a
blessing and you know just keeps
continuing for me I have all new friends
I have a whole new life I don't really
know anybody anymore from the past you
know we had Holly and Bridget here and
they extended the invitation to you I
mean she's welcome to come on the show
if she wants to talk about it we'd love
to hear it do you feel like you would be
open to doing something like that so you
can get to a place of healing and you
can share this message that you're
telling me I've already done the healing
I don't need to you know go on a podcast
and do more healing I've already done it
for myself so what else is there to talk
about
tell me what else is there to talk about
hopefully hopefully some good memories
so hopefully some Reminiscing on the
past
no we've already done that we've already
done we've lived that I lived it I'm
sorry but I have a whole new life that
I've created it's just like a high
school buddy that you lost touch with
sure you wish them all the best I wish
them the best but I just you know as a
person like you just want to you know
just move on yeah yeah yeah let's say
Holly and Bridget somehow we naturally
come back together like that's one thing
but I I don't find healing and doing
podcasts and all that stuff I see it
being a natural thing we do see on
season two of Kendra sells Hollywood you
reunite with Crystal Heffner yeah
Crystal Hefner it's been years
I think everybody's really nice
yeah I think she's a great person
um I just don't know them just because
we dated an in your 80 year old man sure
you have a very interesting Common
Ground there look if if Crystal and I
were to do a real estate transaction
that's that's that's
she flips houses too exactly so we
connected on that so let's throw a party
and sell some houses and yeah enjoy life
moving forward
the agents go to call at any minute
about whether the buyers are signing our
deal or not so beyond stressed waiting
on this counteroff for acceptance season
two I finally sell my first house how'd
that feel
it was the most
amazing feeling and it was such a big
accomplishment to my life and my kids I
want to bring you back two years you
came here to ET to talk about season one
and you told us
I will not have sex again until my first
deal is done it's getting hard I'll tell
you that I need to get laid at some
point so Kendra you sold a house oh
what's the question
I'm just gonna be honest with you
nothing tops the feeling of of closing
your first deal the ultimate high that
is the ultimate orgasm
you close your first deal on on camera
yes
when the world didn't think you could do
it that's sex right there is this a
forever career for you real estate is my
life now
period and I'm doing it for myself and
my kids I really hope it continues for
the show and for people to watch how it
grows because I'm going to make it to
the top
I will what is the goal
to make it to the top of Los Angeles in
the world the world you want to be the
number one selling real estate agent in
the world yep I love it I love that
drive if you hadn't found real estate
where do you think you'd be today
um if
honestly to be honest with you
if I
didn't choose real estate that day
uh
the devil was taking me down
honestly I had nothing left in me I love
my kids and I'm I I live for my kids and
my kids are my purpose and um
and they're my only happiness but you
know there's a lot
that could have taken me down a couple
things I keep reminding myself take care
of yourself you know because I'm alone
I'm alone
take care of yourself
don't do drugs
you know just stay focused
um
words or words you know people are going
to think whatever they want to think of
you it doesn't it doesn't dictate who
you are
just because I have a pass doesn't mean
that that's who I am today now look how
different you are today you get to
rewrite your life if you want to you've
completely reinvented I hope you're so
proud of yourself I am I am very proud
of myself so for all the fans who love
the show and want more are you down for
a season three yes I'm in for a season
three yeah
yeah so that was the answer I was
looking for
season three bring it on if season two
of Kendra sells Hollywood was really
about you getting your mojo back and
really getting your feet planted in the
world of real estate what would a season
three look like
season three would be like
15 levels up I mean up in the game up in
competition because I I'm getting
competitive I might have a side
[Music]